jean paul stahl bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france ce
matin pour répondre à nos questions
alors on a entendu la colère des
restaurateurs pas seulement il ya aussi
lé gérant de salle de sport les
nouvelles mesures sanitaires mises en
place aujourd'hui sont elles justifiées
sur le selon vous est sûrement l
efficace elles sont totalement
indispensable si c'est très simple le
virus circule à partir d'un individu
porteur vers un individu récepteur donc
à partir de ce moment là si on favorise
les contacts entre les personnes eh bien
on favorise la dissémination du virus
il faut pas oublier que depuis le mois
de juin le nombre de cas a été
multipliée par 35
c'est quand même pas rien alors que les
salles de sport ou les les bars et
restaurants soient des lieux des changes
entre personnes c'est logique c'est
normal et c'est fait pour ça mais c'est
aussi là que se transmet en partie le
virus n'y a pas que la bien entendu il
faut pas les stigmatiser sens c'est
cette profession qui est responsable de
la transmission
mais ce type de contact entre êtres
humains et favorisant favorise la
contamination c'est absolument
incontestable et toutes les tous les
appels politiques divers et variés et
quasiment à la désobéissance sont
parfaitement irresponsable alors les
écoles et les universités seraient des
foyers de contamination
pourquoi fermer les restaurants et
salles de sport et laisser les
établissements ouverts alors que
finalement les élèves se retrouvent
aussi dans des espaces clos
donc on a peut-être du mal à comprendre
en fait pourquoi est ce que les
établissements devraient par exemple
rester ouverts alors que les salles de
sport et restaurants devraient fermer
parce que d'abord c'est là je n'ai pas
eu mal les écoles dans les écoles décès
des enfants bien entendu et on sait
qu'ils sont beaucoup moins transmetteur
que c'est risqué
en ce qui concerne les universités elles
peuvent rester ouverte mais avec des
mesures barrières mais il n'est pas dit
qu'elles vont rester ouvertes
c'est absolument pas certain donc c'est
des lieux d'échangé effectivement au
même titre que je sais pas moi un stade
gymnase un restaurant ou un bar et
surtout un bar mais il faut bien avoir
présent à l'esprit que dans un bar vous
buvez délaissés et donc vous enlevez
votre masque dans une université vous
écoutez quand vous gardez un masque et
la différence c'est absolument essentiel
puisque ce sont les mesures barrières
qui évite la transmission du virus
on a dépassé ce week end le million
morts dans le monde du haut coronavirus
ce chiffre ce qui vous inquiète vous
pensez que on pourra dépasser également
ce chiffre pourrait t'il augmenté à bas
certainement il va augmenter il va
augmenter parce que malheureusement
certains pays dans le monde n'ont pas
nos capacités économiques
c'est pour supporter à ce que les
mesures qui sont nécessaires et à partir
de là effectivement le nombre de décès
va inéluctablement augmenté
grossièrement 1 comme base de calcul
on peut considérer que la mortalité se
situe entre selon les endroits entre 0 5
et 1% des cas donc plus vous avez de cas
plus vous avez des sales et c'est
absolument inéluctable deux prix nobel
d'économie ont appelé à ce week end un
confinement rapide pour éviter d'avoir à
re confiné à la population pendant les
fêtes d'année de fin d'année c'est une
hypothèse qui a été rejetée par olivier
vers ans est-ce que cela vous paraît
pertinent vous en tant qu infectieuses
et qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faudrait reconfirmer la population alors
on se heurte finalement un dilemme c'est
à dire que vos américaine exigences
médicales et l'exigence médical c'est
d'isoler isoler les cas et éviter la
transmission c'est à dire éviter les
contacts entre personnes ça c'est la
condition médicale et puis vous avez une
position économique où il faut bien que
le
survivez continue à vivre donc il ya un
difficile équilibre à trouver entre les
deux que les autorités je pense à
présent à l'esprit bien évidemment et je
crois que l'absence de confinement total
peut-être qu'ils aient réclamé rentrer
dans cette cette solution qui est
imparfaite pour tout le monde
je veux dire l'extrême médical ou
l'extrême économique il ya ce ce
difficile exercice d'équilibré
je crois que parfois il faut simplement
s'y pliaient mais c'est simple il n'ya
pas besoin d'un re confinement si les
gens pour suivre les gestes barrière si
on porte un masque les uns les autres
dans les opportunités où on a combat de
transmettre à d'autres il n'y a pas
besoin de confinement leur confinement
c'est vraiment quand on peut rien faire
d'autre et que les gens la population
n'a pas respecté les mesures qu'il
permettait d'éviter leur confinement
respecter les gestes barrière c'est
important merci à jean paul stahl je
rappelle que vous êtes infectiologues au
chu de grenoble merci à vous